doesn't matter what you study so I got a
great question for my newsletter readers
love you guys Rashid who wrote in to say
Evan can a person who never studied
medicine start up a drug shop business
Rashid this is a great question and for
me it all comes down to mindset because
starting any business you're gonna have
challenges it's part of writing the
business okay you don't wake up start a
business and hey money comes flowing
into you there's always gonna be
problems and you're either gonna have
the mindset of looking at those problems
and saying I can't make it that that's
that's the little man mindset right
that's the here all the problems that
exist and why it's not gonna work out or
you're gonna have the mindset of an
entrepreneur which is I'm gonna find the
way I don't care if nobody's even done
this before I'm gonna find the way I'm
not gonna listen to the little man and
I'm gonna be an entrepreneur when I
first started my first business it was a
biotechnology software company okay that
was my first business that hit a big for
me and I had no background in software I
had no background in computers I had no
background in science and Here I am
selling biotechnology software company
science was my worst subject in high
school I dropped it as soon as I could I
think it'd be fun to go back to my old
science teachers where I was you know
getting terrible marks and then tell
them hey you know I was part of a
biotechnology software company selling
this stuff but I think they'd have a
good laugh at that so it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what you study it's
I'm part of this business is what I want
to launch I'm gonna find a way to make
it happen and there may be obstacles
there may be legislation they may be
rules saying hey to own a drugstore you
have to have a PhD in medicine or
whatever it is so maybe you have to have
a partner to come and help you or maybe
you can hire for that position and just
have a manager but you run the business
there's these solutions
there's always solutions any problem
there is there's solutions but you have
to have the mindset so the real question
is
do you believe that it's possible if you
believe that it's not possible and
you're listening to the little man then
you're never gonna make but if you
believe that it is possible then you
will believe those are watching you like
the video you can support me by clicking
on the link in the description leave a
comment let me know what you think and
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon